la macworld s'écoute je suis
relativement enfants depuis sept ans le
bal à dos de mcquaid et l'un des plus
populaires au québec certains épisodes
ont été écoutés plus de 275 mille fois
je suis un petit radio canada john cage
le ballade you may cry sous écoute et
diffusé sur plusieurs plateformes dont
youtube google play et itunes
le format se prête bien au site d'humour
de mcquaid s'est liberté totale nous ont
dit aux habitants en arrivant il y aura
pas de montage le bal à dos ou le
podcast est une émission courtes ou
longues disponible sur le web
podcast humoristique que les phénomène a
pris une telle ampleur que depuis deux
ans le gala les olivier romain prix aux
meilleurs balade ou humoristiques
mcquaid est en nomination mais il a de
la compétition
je pense qu'à chaque fois qu'on entend
pas d'casqué déjà qu'on a c'est quoi pas
de cas pacheco qui en est le plus
possible de nommer la gac et déjà titre
de game curieux d'en recruter plusieurs
styles de balados on est dans les
dernières années il y en as
d'information d'opinion ou de fiction
josiane critique août entre autres les
balades aux disparus de radio-canada et
la cuisine de jean philippe du chef jean
philippe cyr qui parle de véganisme une
grande fan de documentaires en général
j'aime beaucoup regarder sauf que avec
ma vie d'étudiante et tout bon jeu
manque de pain donc je me suis rabattu
sur les balados nous on écoute beaucoup
quand je cours d'or ou quand je marche
ça me permet de vraiment rentrer dans ma
bulle
selon l'observateur des technologies
médias au printemps dernier un canadien
sur cinq déclaré avoir écouté un balado
au cours du dernier mois
même que du côté des anglophones c'était
un sur quatre aujourd'hui les gens
peuvent écouter en fait un contenu audio
cependant la rue dans le métro à la
campagne en voyage en fête en voiture
etc
c'est comme si on a allongé dans le fond
la capacité de rejoindre non
à travers la technologie à travers le
téléphone qui rit probable signe que le
phénomène prend de l'ampleur les
amateurs de balade où se réuniront en
fin de semaine au cinéma moderne pour le
festival résonances festival de balados
ici à londres et d'un orage au canada
montréal